you've got one side that's upset  that more babies are going to live and  then you've got another side that's  happy that they're going to live and  also they're kind of revealing  um some things that they said that were  total nonsense like for example we're  hearing in the media all these  lamentations about abortion clinics  closing planned parenthood clinics are  closing all over the country we're  supposed to be upset about that of  course it's like that i couldn't be  happier to see those people unemployed  but also they i thought they said that  abortion was only three percent of what  planned parenthood does so why would  rove being overturned  i mean that  doesn't make any sense